now that you've seen a bunch of
activities for the defined stage I want
you to get practice breaking down an
overall product experience into much
simpler steps your task is to create a
golden path for users to successfully
use the shopping app now keep in mind
the golden path should only have the
main are the essential steps that a user
takes to find the real value that they
came for the product in the first place
supporting threads such as editing
orders or creating accounts are
secondary to the golden path you can
include those but they're not really
essential for the main tasks that the
user we need to perform and remember
that you should be thinking in terms of
stories rather than pages this helps you
prioritize the central or the key user
journey so go ahead and create a golden
path for the superduper shopping app
keep in mind the previous personas the
first tweet and the one-page executive
summary you can see the instructor notes
for these materials once you're ready
check this box to continue